Marla maples hit you yeah like you can't
back out this is real this is happening
it's totally real now and there is no
backing out there is no going home we
are in it to win it the X Factor in
questions about Trump off limits married
from 1993 to 99 their daughter Tiffany
has been on the campaign trail and Marla
is rebooting her life now my time to
step up with what I believe is wild card
reporter Geraldo Rivera has Marla's back
my Canon mezra Marla maples life must be
like the poor thing that's probably why
she's been underground I think I salute
her courage we're calling Kim fields
tango tuti she's the former facts of
life cutie who's now mom to two boys
we're hoping the old gang cheers are all
we might have a couple of surprises from
a couple of my back to life and a family
and some of the living single family I
like yeah we told you last week fuller
house sweetheart Jodie Sweetin was
aboard she's scared about Dancing live
because on her sitcom she gets do-overs
it's fun you get the energy of a live
audience but if you screw up it's like
okay we'll do it again and actress
Mischa Barton might be the comeback kid
in 2007 former OC star was busted for
DUI spend time in a psych ward and Rehab
look at healthy she's making a fresh
start
why was this the perfect time in her
life just sign up for that if previous
years it just didn't really fit into my
schedule or feel right or everything
else that was going on in my life and
this year does